welcome back to las vegas now it's very
important to put your cancer care
and do not put your cancer care and
screenings on hold during this time
i spoke to dr gallard of optimum care to
learn more take a look
so let's just start with the basics you
know define cancer for people well
it's a term that's used for a whole
constellation of diseases
in which abnormal cells divide without
the normal control
these cells can invade other tissues
and radically shorten and change one's
life
what do these cancer screenings actually
involve
well they're different for each type of
disease mammograms for instance are the
best way to find
breast cancer early when it's easiest to
treat
the pap test for cervical cancer can
find
abnormal cells before it turns
into an advanced cancer specifically the
hpv
test looks for evidence of the human
papilloma virus
that can cause cell changes now
colorectal cancer
is a disease that develops from
pre-cancerous
polyps within the colon
screening tests look for these polyps
and remove them
before they become a full-fledged cancer
wow and what can viewers actually do for
themselves to reduce
the risk of getting cancer
well uh for one thing eliminate high
risk activities
uh for instance with lung cancer stop
smoking
limit your exposure to secondhand smoke
skins cancer sunscreen really
limits your exposure to to the sun
where some protective clothing wear a
hat wear sunglasses
also limiting alcohol alcohol
can be a co-factor in all sorts
of cancers specifically oral cancers
throat cancers
and a large number of other cancers
including breast cancer and even
colorectal cancer
so really limiting that intake
wow that is very very helpful that's a
great reminder
yeah in addition um staying fit
and what are some of the new advances in
cancer treatment because i know it
continues to evolve
well we really have seen extraordinary
results there's a treatment called car t
cell therapy where one's own immune
cells are genetically engineered to
fight
certain types of cancer specifically
certain types of leukemia and lymphoma
uh the foundations for cancer treatment
have been
surgery and chemotherapy and radiation
radiation therapy
and we have really built on these it's
immunotherapy though
that is where we use the body's
own immune system to fight cancer i
think it's extremely
exciting we're making what seemed to be
decades worth of advances
very very quickly optimum care cancer
care has locations across southern
nevada for more information call that
number on your screen or just visit
optimcare.com envy cancer care
we'll be right back